view here okay hi hi everyone right hi
everyone and welcome to the workshop I'm
just gonna give a very short
introduction and then little mistake
over so i'm tráfico lessor and the
director of the simon's institute you
know we are having a wonderful Smiths we
were having a wonderful semester having
all of you come to Berkeley some a
permanent basis in a sense of a few
months in some shorter and at this point
we're doing everything remotely I wanted
to just say a few guidelines we have a
panelists who are able to speak at any
time we have for the rest of the
participants who can post question and
answers and then one of the panelists
will let the speaker know of the
questions and answers I think even the
speaker himself has access to it but I
assume that the program organizers
themselves will give you more detailed
instructions over how how they want to
run it and specifically their workshop
organizers I want to thank everybody for
making the effort to join remotely I
want to thank the organizers especially
of this workshop who have completely
switched a program around to make sure
that people all around the world can
join with respect to their time zones I
know that's not trivial to do the work
twice then the work before the program
during the program and now again for
this remote participation and I hope
everyone as well and for my sake I guess
so when you speak it would be great if
you say your names and are you talking
from least in the beginning
so that's all I'm gonna say you know
usually we we talk about okay and yes
you can't hear me the whole time
no oh my god we heard you oh I thought
somebody said something I just wanted to
say that we usually have all kinds of
instructions about what you can cannot
bring to the auditorium and that sort of
thing obviously you can do whatever you
want but hopefully do it quietly so
welcome everyone and I think who mesh is
going to take over from here
say a few words go ahead and wish
sorry I'm muted okay hi Sophie thanks so
thanks everybody for for coming to this
workshop this virtual workshop it's I
guess a new regime here at assignments
so let me just say a few words about
about this the intent of this workshop
so as you probably know quantum
protocols have become a pretty central
part of the entire enterprise all the
way from from physically testing quantum
systems to bei theoretical questions
about what the power of multiple
approvers is and so in fact this this
workshop as you can as you can imagine
it's evolved a lot over time as this as
this current crisis has has developed
and and so there as a surety said the
organizers had a lot to do in in terms
of keeping up with with with what is
happening and and and restructuring
their program so the way the program is
now and d1 and a for a deal with with
the physical aspects of you know
benchmarking and tomography so how do
you characterize quantum systems using
physical assumptions there there's a you
know so so this this entire workshop is
is as as you can imagine structured
around how do you interrogate quantum
systems so and how do you how do you get
to understand various properties of the
system or or get information out of it
and and so there's there in addition to
this physical model there's also a
cryptographic ways as you can do this
interrogation and that was actually much
of that actually took place in last
week's workshop where which was with the
latus program and then there's the two
and three of this program has to do with
multiple provers which are not
interacting and how a classical verify
can can interact with with these
multiple
rumors and of course the the star of
that you know of that entire subject is
the recent MIT star equal to re result
which is you know absolutely stunning
and so the hope is you know so what
you'll hear about is is the basics of
that results so by the by the end of the
day two and three hopefully you'll
understand the the the bones of that
result the consequences and you know the
motivation as well as some variants of
the model okay now there was one thing
that that was casualty to this this
crisis which is there the organizers had
actually set up these talks by
experimentalist to talk about actual
experiments about about some of these
topics and unfortunately that part had
to be cancelled I should say a couple of
words about about how how to approach
this meeting I hope that that that the
audience will take take part in the
meeting you know that will make it as
interactive as possible so please ask
lots of questions and you know there's
there's also some ways in which this
this zoom setting this online setting
you know well we'll try to make it as
you know as good as possible as as an
interactive in essence I mean uh but
there are some ways in which it may it
might even be be better so for example
this chat on the side one way you can
think about it is well you know if
you're in the attending a talk with your
favorite person besides you you can sort
of have a little bit conversation to
clarify things that you're not
understanding well you can use the chat
app where you can ask questions and then
actually if you're watching the chat and
if you see a question that you know how
to answer actually answer it and that
can that can take the place of this this
sort of informal interaction on the side
and then the the panelists will pick up
on questions which are which which might
be of more general interest or which
haven't been answered and actually
either unmute you or ask speaker
directly
about those questions so okay well with
that introduction I shouldn't take up
much more of your time except to say but
thank you to all the speakers who agreed
to to speak during these next few days
and and of course thanks to all the
organizers I should turn the mic over to
the wreaths who is chairing the first
session okay
managed to amuse myself thanks so much
so it's really nice to see everyone at
least by name on the side and I should
say they're sort of there's the chat
window but there's also the question and
answers window which I'm not sure if
that was used before in the conference
before but that could be also used if
you want to sort of single out a
question that I will see and if I manage
to actually see it I will forward it and
say it aloud
I can also unmute you guys at various
points if anybody wants so maybe I think
we have one more minute so maybe I'll
say one thing about about how this
conference worked and following what
mesh was starting to say well somehow
this conference is about the connection
between well we have a system which is
exponentially hard to characterize and
verify and over the past I don't know a
decade or so there's been a lot of work
in from various directions asking this
question
some of them is more from the physics
side where you don't have the need to
assume completely malicious systems or
environments but there are lots of
assumptions that you can make and and in
the workshop we have a lot of talks from
that side about benchmarking and about
the talk that we're just going up that
we're just
to here by a tie of other ways to do
that now on the other extreme there is
sort of the malicious or the
cryptographic setting where the system
is completely against us the physical
system and want to understand what
happens there in the completely
malicious case and we'll hear a lot
about this and what when we organized
the schedule for the workshop and we set
up the the different talks we thought of
actually putting together the two
different sides of cryptography and
characterization verification from the
more physics side so the most malicious
up to the physical setting and see
whether the different approaches and
techniques can can can be of interest to
the different sides so with that in mind
let's start with a tie on from Technion
who is who's going to tell us about the
more physics approach be tight so now
can you talk it I I can't talk can you
hear me yes good yes okay so and I hope
you can see the screen it's okay yes
it's okay
okay so so first I want to thank the the
organizer for organizing these this
conference in spite of all the corona
virus and everything and so thank you
thank you very much and it's a great
honor to be the first speaker so I hope
everything works fine okay so so as the
weight was saying I'm going to talk
about verification and characterization
of quantum systems many-body quantum
systems and I'm going to do it a little
bit from the physics side it will not be
so much in from the crypto side and this
is war this is a work which is based on
on two papers with with collaborators
with a very Antonelli
from the Technion and lo to and dario
Poletti co2 from qi lab in china and
dario platy from CTD in singapore and
the talk is based on on these two papers
okay so so what exactly the problem I'm
trying to describe and so in here are
two attacking here is the problem of
characterize characterization and
verification in the neck area and is
nearly of noisy intermediate quantum
systems so we are giving a mid-sized
noisy quantum device the one for example
that Google used to show some sort of
supremacy so this is a very this this
device is extremely noisy on one side on
the other side it is also very large so
that we cannot no longer simulate it
classically and and the question is that
how do we characterize this type of
system we need to characterize it if you
want to optimize the gates the dynamic
and also we need it you need to
characterize it we need to verify it if
we if we want to be sure that the device
is is is doing what it is supposed to be
we feel is supposed to find a ground
state of a certain Hamiltonian and it's
supposed to do simulate the den time
dynamics of a Hamiltonian to some sort
of a simple quantum circuit we want to
be able to to verify that it is indeed
doing its task so so this is the general
problem that I am trying to study here
okay and and the approach that I want to
present here is a is a relatively new
approach and it is based in in a sense
it is based on the non commutativity of
the of the quantum generators so in some
sense this is a purely quantum theory
quantum approach and and as you see it
will be kind of useless or worthless in
the classical setting and these are the
details of the of the two papers
it is based on the first paper was
applying this method for closed system
for Hamiltonians
and and the second system was extended
it to open system more specifically tool
in bludgeon systems okay so so let's
talk about a little bit about
verification so as the rate was saying
before I before when we talk about
verification we can we can roughly
divide it into into two to power to two
different types of verifications there
is one very big body of work of
verification from the cryptographic
standpoint and these these work they
they have certain assumptions and and
this is something usually usually in the
assumption we are dealing with a
malicious party we're trying to increase
in order to to deal with these parties
and many times very often we are not too
concerned about about noise simply maybe
it's simply because it is already very
complicated to to ensure security
without noise and and then in these
systems while we we have certain certain
assumptions that we takes for example we
can assume that the verifier has had a
small red quantum register on which it
can work and and you know he can handle
it perfectly it's clean
quantum register and is completely
private or we can have the assumption
that there are actually two quantum
provers but they are we are not we know
that there are very distant apart so we
can use some sort of CH SH game or we
can use some sort of computational
assumptions like learning with errors in
order to guarantee that we are not
fooled by the by the prover so but most
of these assumptions are not very
relevant
when we when if we are trying to verify
misc
and nice device and a noisily
intermediate scale device and in these
circumstances well the problem is that
we have a very noisy system but on one
side but on the other side we we don't
really have a malicious malicious party
okay I mean nature might be very noisy
but it is not malicious so so we usually
we might take different assumptions for
example that noise is not a adversely
correlated or that only certain types of
measurements or gate or allowed or
certain geometries and cetera et cetera
and and the and the set up that I'm
going to talk about is is exactly this
set up of of that of the of the misc
error okay so when we talking when when
we want to characterize and noisy
devices there are several approaches by
far I think the on the top of the hill
we have randomized benchmarking which is
a better that has been around for I
guess something like 15 years
it is extremely robust it is very
scalable one of the best best things
about it that it is insensitive to to
spam error to state preparation and
measurement error and and in some
instances it is also very scalable on
the other hand it gives us a very
relatively limited information about
about the noise in the system and and
and what is going on what is actually
going on there it gives us some sort of
an average fidelity or or in the end it
is relatively a low number of parameters
that can extract out of this out of this
method on the other extreme there are
some sort of tomography like protocols
for example gates a tomography which
gives us a very detailed information
about the noisiness system
but exactly what kind of gates actually
we are applying but it is this it is not
really very scalable and so the question
that I'm trying to answer here is
whether there is somewhere something in
the middle that we that we can do
something will give us more information
probably then then randomized net
marking and yet would be would be a bit
more scalable for example than gates at
tomography
maybe if we we might even maybe with the
sacrifice of some assumptions and also
most of all so importantly even if we in
both of this set up in randomized
benchmarking and you negate set remember
fie we're kind of we're kind of doing
characterization of single gates or a
single measurement operation but what we
would like in the next step is to able
to put everything together into and see
if it actually works when it tries to
simulate a particular a Newtonian or try
to execute a particular circuit so in
some sense this is only these things
only apply for the first step and you
want to see how they how they work
together are they coordinate together so
this is another thing that I will try to
to address here okay so so as I was
saying what I'm going to talk about is
how to use the non commutativity of the
quantum operators to characterize and
verify many-body quantum systems okay
and in some sense the entire approach
can be can be stated in two words and
first theorem and the theorem is is this
theorem here which you can which you can
see let's assume I mean here so here I'm
talking about let's assume we have a
closed system governed by a Hamiltonian
H so we know that the time evolution of
the system if it is a closed system is
given by by this equation the new time
to revisit derivative of Rho
the system is given by minus I times the
commutator of H with role if we now
multiply it by some observable a and
take the trace then we can we
immediately get the infest theorem that
states how the expectation value of an
observable how it develops in time so
let us now consider a steady state state
in which the system the system does not
evolve so the time derivative of role is
zero and therefore also the time
derivative of every expectation value of
every observable will also vanish in
this case what we will get is is this
equation here that the average of the
commutator of H with any observable a
will be equal to zero this is what I
want to use I want to take this equation
and and and see all the type of
constraints that it implies and use it
in order to characterize and verify h
and the dynamic that it generates so so
how can we use it for example to learn
the local Hamiltonian so so let's assume
we have a system that sits on a lattice
like this system here so for example
let's assume it's a 2d lattice with
nearest neighbor it's interaction and
let us assume that we are giving some
sort of a steady state of the system and
but we don't know the Hamiltonian we
don't know the underlying Hamiltonian so
how can we how can we recover it from
the other underlying state so the idea
is to expand first of all H in terms of
a basis of law in tennis some basis of
local interactions because we assume it
is it is a local system with local
interactions so this basis must be of
polynomial size for example if it is a
to local ami tone and this basis should
be of the order of n squared where n is
the number of spins in the system and
moreover if it is nearest neighbors
interaction its it should be of even of
the order of n and so we can pick up
this kind of basis for example it can be
some products of power bases
and and then plug it in plugging it into
the equation that we saw before what we
get is we get these these this set of
equations for the for the for the
coefficients es of the different basis
elements in which we expanded H and the
idea of the method that I want to
present is simply to take a few of these
of these operators a let's let's let's
number them by one to two capital N and
for each one of these operators we will
get a set of we will get a constraint
and equation for the coefficients es and
put all these constraints together we
obtain this type of linear linear linear
homogeneous equation where KJ s now the
matrix of the equation is given its
entries are given by the commutator of
the basis element PS will be observable
AJ so so okay so this is the base the
basic equation and the idea is that we
can now measure these this expectation
value by measuring this expectation
value we can measure their the matrix k
KJ s and by and then by looking for the
for its for its kernel we can find these
these coefficients yes and from from
using these coefficients we can simply
recover H so going on I want to I want
to stress that this method relies on or
the non commutativity of the underlying
quantum quantum dynamics and why is that
so yes yes sorry um so what go back
aside so this expectation value is with
respect to what state again to some
steady state that I'm even I'm giving
some some steady state role which is
which I assume is a steady state of the
amazonian and therefore I know that this
this equation is
holls so the expectation value of h with
any of the commutator of h with any
observable age should vanish so it's a
steady state like an eigenvector like
would be an eigenvector but it doesn't
have to be a negative it can be any
convex combination of eigenvectors it
can be for example a give state okay
yeah
the we assume that the PS they are known
and we are yes try how to see us
yes exactly the PS are known i mean i
mean what i'm doing here i'm using prior
knowledge i'm using i mean i assume that
the hamiltonian is for example is to
local and nearest neighbors so that will
that will dictate the type of PS that
i'm using so we'll use you know only
product of power is of nearest neighbor
qubits for example okay so so as I was
saying what would hide what would hide
behind this method is is the non
commutativity of the and to see why this
is true let's see let's try to convince
ourselves that it cannot work in the
commuting case so let's assume we have
now a local Hamiltonian that it is made
of these small ages so it's the sum of
this H I and let's assume it's commuting
local Omicron and so these H is commute
with each other and if we have a if we
have an eigenstate of the system which
commute with all these H I so we have
another steady convex combination of
these eigen bases then in sums then that
would mean that that the troll is
compatible with every H with this which
is the linear which is a linear
combination of these H I in other words
if Rho commutes with every small H I it
will also commute with every linear
combination of these small H I and so it
will commute with with every with every
Hamiltonian that is that is given by
such a linear combination and and as a
result but it means it means that
actually this
this linear equation that we will obtain
the K matrix we will measure system well
it will have a huge degenerate space and
B and the dimension of the space will be
as at least the size of the of the
different of the number of the the of
the H is there again please the matrix K
yeah so so this is the matrix K okay
okay so if all H is meaning all P SS
commute with each other then how do we
see that that all CSS are no you will
not you will not you will not see the H
eyes are not appeared the penis is a
known basis okay
the piece is a known basis and and and
the H I might be unknown it for example
it might be some local Hamiltonian that
commutes with itself I know the Torah
code for example or whatever you don't
know it a priori okay this is what you
want to learn but I'm saying that what
I'm saying is that the the the only
thing on which the on which the method
the method relies it relies on the
assumption that H commutes that H
commutes with with role in some sense
okay this is this is everything the the
method relies on Saudi the commutator of
H with Rho is is the easy time
derivative is the derivative of Rho and
so if if Rho is a steady state it means
that this commutator is zero so
everything relies on the fact that that
H commutes with Rho but if H is made of
of local operators that all commutes
with themselves and you can you have
that in for a given role you can come up
with an infinite number of HS that will
commute with it and therefore that what
it implies it implies a piece that
necessarily this method will yell it
will be a should be able to yell it each
each in one of these edges so it means
that this equation can see equal to zero
must have a lot of solutions so
etai um yeah so can I ask so let's say
that you're you are trying to
characterize a quantum system but let's
say you don't know you know maybe maybe
actually it was a it was a classical
system and so now you write write down
these constraints and they're noisy so
would you just end up getting some kind
of unstable solution so you know in
practice you probably won't because of
noise it couldn't be d generate any more
but but now what you just get an
arbitrary solution noise well what I we
will get to it but my guess is that what
what you will what you will what you
will see you will see because because it
will be noisy so there will be probably
a unique there will be only one guy that
minimizes in some sense I mean you will
you will never get a pure case equal to
zero solution just because of the noise
but you will get in a polynomially many
solutions which are all very very close
to zero okay you will not have you will
not have like a unique solution and then
a guy above it okay okay so so because
this method will not work for commuting
for commuting Hamiltonians then it will
be it will be useless for classical
systems so now let me let me just
describe the the algorithm to summarize
what the method what we what we do is we
start with we we start with H for the P
expanding in terms of unknown
coefficients of some basis of I know for
example if it is local interact in local
two-body interactions so it will be some
sort of power list for example then we
will then we will come up with an and
observables and we will
this end will be greater thing than em
the number of basis elements and we will
use small end measurements to estimate
the entry matrix at this of this case so
it will be tilt cage I guess it will be
an approximation for the areal cages
which is the expectation value of this
commutator and then because it will only
be an approximation to the real case we
don't expect it to have to have an exact
zero vector so instead of zero vector we
will find we will find the minimal the
minimal right eigenvector of it if you
wish or we will find the vector that
minimizes the norm of of K times time C
or in other words this will be just the
the ground state of these positive seven
positive definite matrix which we get by
taking K dagger time K okay so we can
now do a little bit of analysis of how
this method works well just as much said
the K that we get in the algorithm is
not the real cake it is approximation to
the K and we have we have some we have
some we have some noise due to the
statistical to the fact that we are only
using sampling from a finite number of
measurements so how do we know how far
is the see the solution that we get from
the actual solution and B and the idea
is that right now the reason for the
approximation is just the fact that
there is statistical noise meaning that
you have estimations of some random
that's right sorry there's no noise
there's no you didn't introduce noise in
the measurements or anything like that
yeah I assume you're you're perfectly
right I assume here that my measurement
so perfect that's right I mean the
algorithm only uses measurement in some
sense so so it assumed that I'm you that
I'm only using measurement but the
measurement of effort and in moreover in
in that sense it also assumes that the
many different copies that I'm using in
order to generate the statistics are all
identical to each other
that's another assumption that goes into
it okay so so the kief to understand how
how how c is different from the from C
Till's so how did the measure C is the
actual C's is to look at the at the
spectral gap of this matrix K and so it
would not be very surprising to see that
if K has a spectral gap so if the actual
K the real K has only one 0 vector and
above its although all day of the
singular on the similar vectors singular
values that come about it are separated
by a gap then this then then our
algorithm will be stable in the sense
that if we if K tilde is only
approximately Cape then still see CT L
will be close to C and and we can we can
it's not very difficult to prove it
rigorously so there is we have this
theorem here that says that if K is the
exact and by M constraint matrix and if
k TL is the empirical approximation to
it then with hyper and if we're using an
S measurement and with with high
probability Delta this distance between
the empirical solution and the exact
solution will be upper bounded by by
this expression here and as you can see
the key the key element that goes in
here is is the spectral that is this is
this lambda 1 here so in other words in
order to in order to get some reliable
results
we will need something of the order of n
/ the spectral gap squirt measurement
and the theorem is quite standard I mean
to prove it
we use words inequalities for singular
values plus the matrix Chernoff bound
and yeah this is it so okay so what what
it what it also tells us is that so what
we also learned from that is the first
well the spectral gap is it is the most
important thing here and but and we and
while it is unfortunate that we that
given a certain model it's it's not easy
to to know a priori what kind of speckle
gap this constraint matrix K will have
this is something that we can verify a
posteriori I mean we can we can measure
we can calculate K tilde and we can see
if it has a gap if there's a gap then we
know we safe and we know that our
results are okay so this is I think an
important point okay and so let me give
several remarks of it about it if if the
steady state that we are using is it's a
pure state so in other words if it is if
it is an eigenstate of age and we are
using all possible AJ constraints so not
only these local AJ but all type of
observables then the condition that K is
annihilated by C will just become this
condition that the variance of of of the
energy on Ansari is vanishing and this
is exactly the condition of Kia not from
their paper in 2017 and in the method
that they they pioneered for for
learning a local a metonym for mystical
eigenstate so in some sense our method
generalizes there
the result by by allowing allowing us
also to work not only with with the
steady state that our eigenstate of
Hamiltonian but with any convex
combination with any of I can say in
other words with any with any role that
is commuting with the Hamiltonian
another advantage of our method is that
because this AI these constraints AI can
be can be local and we this method is
extremely local in the center if you
only want to recover a local patch of
the system if you want to learn a local
patch of the system then all we have to
do is is is use local a is use local ace
that sit on this on this patch and as a
result all the constraint that will get
will only will only involve the the part
of H that is that is that acts on this
on this patch so so okay so this this
only me this also means that if there
are if there are some beds you know if
there are some other places in the
system that don't work very well it
probably might not influence our you
know the result in other patches another
point is that we can also use several
state States together in order to to get
stronger constraints and and for
implicitly increase the gap in in K so
using several for example using gibbsite
at several temperatures for example or
using different eigen states I wish that
I got it right so in the classical case
that you talked earlier about we would
just have the case that the lambda 1 is
0 and that's why it doesn't work because
you would need infinitely many
measurements according to your formula
right yes ok and we have another
question
ah hi this is Lee Barford from keysight
technologies no measurement is perfect
so but to decide whether the measurement
error is so small that it can be ignored
the measurement needs to be thoroughly
understood what measurements then are
you proposing to estimate the K tilde
matrix and what's its what's what's
there measurement error characteristics
yeah so that's a very good point and as
I was saying different different
approaches take different assumptions
and currently in this assumption that
I'm using I'm assuming boldly and
unjustifiably perfect measurements and
and one of the open questions that I
would like to write in the end is how to
incorporate this method and how to
generalize it to handle also biases into
measurements and errors in the
measurements but currently everything
that I'm talking about I'm assuming
perfect measurements if I can ask so do
you have an intuitive even an intuitive
understanding of lambda1 so what is it
is there any any way to understand what
it depends upon and when it would be
large
well it certainly depends upon how about
the non-communist of the how the how you
need a lot of a lot of these local terms
in the mattoni on in order to annihilate
the ground state or commute with the
ground state so for example another case
where the gap closes down is when you
have a frustration-free Hamiltonian we
doesn't have to be commuting but if even
if it is only commuting on a single
eigenstate and you're trying to recover
it from that eigenstate then you will
also run in the problem simply because
you know there are many different
Hamiltonians that are compatible I mean
if there is one frustration fear
Newtonian on that eigenstate and there
are many different other frustration
Freeman just multiplied them by some
positive number so so it's not excessive
it tells you how
a little bit about the angle of between
no between the action of the different
of the different local terms of their
meat onion on this on this steady-state
that's my my intuition thank you okay so
let me let me give you some some
numerical results that we have these are
very simple numerical results so for
example if we trying in the first the
first example is is like the result run
and sample of random Hamiltonians and we
we artificially added some some
measurement noise to them so it is here
it is 10 to the minus 4 it's very
realistic but this is what we've done
here and what wish what what what we've
seen in this graph is the y-axis tells
you the this Delta the the the
difference between the the exact the
exact Hamiltonian and the the
reconstructed Hamiltonian and n tells
you the number of local constraints that
you're using and as you can see when we
increase and we gradually improve the
quality of reconstruction until we kind
of saturate and there is a big change
here around 100 which which is you know
the mini twist our the number of
constraints we use suppresses the number
of basis elements in in in in H then we
start saying non-trivial results another
example is when we can do much better
actually is when we have some sort of
prior knowledge on the amazonian so so
in the first example we knew nothing
about the EMA tonin except that they are
nearest neighbors and sitting on the
line but to local but we didn't know
anything about the the form of the
actual operators here in sec
example we we allow ourselves to we know
much much more than that we we assume
that the a metonym is of that form with
only two unknown parameters capital J
and H and and then accordingly what you
can see is that with very high noise
level of 0.1 we can still recover we can
still recover the Hamiltonian to a very
good to a very good accuracy and this is
this is like one of the I think one of
the strengths is of this of this method
is that you can you can insert some sort
of prior knowledge and you can also
always sell consistently check yourself
to see to see if this if this solution
that you got of this C actually
minimizes the K if you know that it
minimizes then it gives you okay so I'm
on the on the right on the right spot on
the right region this is another example
where we no longer learn the Hamiltonian
from from pure state or from the ground
state we actually learn it from from a
Gib state so not surprisingly the
quality of the reconstruction depends
highly on the on the temperature as the
temperature rises the Gib state will
become will approach the completely
mixed state and clearly this state is
compatible with many different
Hamiltonian so that that applies that
the quality must degrade or in other
words the gap in Kay must must must
shrink and this is indeed what we see in
this graph as we increase the
temperature the quality of the
reconstruction drops so let me now try
view several extensions of this of this
idea one extension that we can do is do
that week is that we can take big the
very same ID and extend it to open
system instead of talking about
Hamiltonians we can now talk about for
example in your dragons and in valiums
are just
our models for system that open quantum
system and they involve evolving in some
with some interaction with the
environment and assuming this
interaction is is Markovian and
and short-range short-range etc one can
derive these operators LS that describe
them in blood yin and the evolution of
density matrix is now governed by this
in blood young equation limpid equation
so there in addition to the commutator
with H that we saw before we now have
all this this these extra terms of which
is a dissipation but because because of
the commutator is here then the entire
MA in time mathematical structure that
we had before comes right through and we
can do everything like we did before we
can do it on this underlying equation
and therefore you can also derive this
sum this generalized infest equation for
the for the expectation value of any
observable a and
so we get something like that and from
this from this equation we can we can
write up we can what we can do is we can
expand the the different s operators in
the basis and and and and write down
their coefficient as CSR and essentially
everything just follows through all we
have to do is now use the larger vector
to describe the system one part will
describe the amazonian the other part
will describe these LS operators and we
will have a k matrix and everything will
be just to say this method can be very
useful in in learning noise in quantum
computers I think a good model to the
noise in quantum computers is some sort
of in in blood yin so maybe this method
can be used to
to learn this the different generator of
the limburgian and this is an example of
using this method numerically on the
reversion of six six particles again we
use some sort of random Hamiltonian with
a random limburgian
and as you can and as you can see the
when we add more and more constraint to
the system the quality of the
reconstruction improves there is another
interesting thing about this open system
is the question give me a second yeah so
Philippe you can you can talk okay
thanks yeah it was only about the
actually about the previous flights but
maybe I just didn't notice but I wanted
a spot exelon
exactly meant in those okay so so Epson
was the uncertainty in the K matrix that
we got due to the finite number of
measurements right okay okay you like
that but uncertainty in like on the
level of the expectation value of the
whole matrix or like the single entry
under single entry okay right okay and
the second maybe I didn't notice also
like what are the dimensions on those
plots on the holes on the previous notes
which like here yeah yeah because yeah
there is just how many particles are
hearing okay so in these numerical
results
these were usually very small models of
like 12 particles or 10 particles
something like that we did the exact
documentation in some sense there we
also did some MPs simulations I don't
have the graphs here in which we
simulated something like 100 particles
for example in budget for example and
then we we we looked we looked at a
small region of the system and we
managed to reconstruct the rim dadan of
that small region ok nice thank you
I'm sorry just a quick follow-up you
know each ISO so I was always expecting
epsilon to relate to the to the actual
Hamiltonian you were learning and how
accurately you learnt it but you said it
was related to the K matrix yes so
epsilon so epsilon is is because we did
everything numerically so so epsilon is
actually the the error that you get from
having perfect measurement with finite
statistics so we added we added this
this noise that behaves as if you were
as if you were you were you know you
were measuring only with the finite
number of measurements and so every your
empirical averages will be will be
different from the exact one and by by
this order okay so what I was saying is
that another thing that is interesting
about this open system is that it can in
a it can enable us to use this method to
learn a classical Hamiltonian actually
so the idea is that you know you take a
classical Newtonian and you add to it
these dissipators okay this quantum guys
that might not commute with it but you
know might for example dissipate you
toward a certain certain certain states
but the the steady state will be also
affected by the
so the steady state will we'll have the
steady state of the global system will
have some information about this
Amazonia so even though the maternal is
completely classical and you and you
will be unable to learn it using our
method if you only looked at the closed
system of this Hamiltonian if you look
at the combination of this Hamiltonian
plus some dissipators some of this of
this open system then you will be able
to then you will be able to learn it
you will because the the entire dynamics
is it's not computing now you will be
able to also now recover the classical
Newtonian so this is an example where we
we are learning there is a classical
random Isaac model to local for example
nearest neighbors of six pins and we are
adding some no dissipation to it this
these guys will be the l.e.d.s operators
and together the system goes to a non
trivial steady state and by using our
method on that steady state we are able
to recover the classical the classical
random amazonian with very good with
very good accuracy so you know even with
sorry so how does this compare to other
methods for learning classical
hamiltonians
are you going to talk about it later
because I don't the set up is not really
classical in that sense right I mean
right but if you are trying to learn
classical Hamiltonians you think I
assume there are other ways right well
as I will mention it there is there is a
way I mean there a famous problem is to
learn the GEEP state of a classical
Newtonian this is known as for example
the postman machine of Markov random
field so so these in this system
something you have lower bound you have
lower bound and these these problems
might
sometimes the exponential whereas here
everything depends on the gap so you
know it could be that you might be able
to learn these local a maternal more
efficiently using using these methods I
don't know I don't have a good answer I
mean it all depends on the gap in the
end okay so the and the final extension
that I want to to propose is is to
extend this method to dynamics if we now
return to the end test equation here
then we might not consider only
steady-state but actually states that
evolve in time and so we will not
disregard the left-hand side of this
equation and what we can do now if we
have a system that actually will be
impulse evolves in time is that it
evolved for some capital time T we will
get this equation dividing it by T we
will we will get now this equation and
what you can see is that actually this
integral can now be written as some sort
of an effective density matrix row
average that I've written here which is
given as the average of all the of all
the densities matrices along the time
evolution and we will get as a result of
this equation we will now if we do the
same as the mathematics that we did
before we will now get a non-homogeneous
equation we will get the same K but this
time it will be equal to some to some
non-homogeneous term which will come
from this side of the equation and we
can just as we did before we can just
measure these this K empirically and and
use it in order to recover to recover C
so this is the this is the equation that
we are using for 40 goes to infinity
this this state here that we have this
this average row will actually go into a
convex combination of
of all the of all the eigen states that
participate in the initial state with
positive weights so it will be it will
it will be a steady state of H of course
and it will commute with H so 40 goes
through into infinity if we if we evolve
the system for a long time then then we
can actually use the previous method and
here all the information about the
amazonian will only be stored in K in
noting this B because now the B will
disappear because we are taking T to
infinity so everything will be in K
which can be a problem a problem for
example because it can have a small gap
and what we will need we will need many
measurements probably in order to to
sample this this expectation values
along the time evolution but the good
thing about this method is is that now
it will be much less sensitive to
preparation errors okay because we are
looking at steady States in some sense
effective steady states so it will be it
will save us from all sort of
systematical errors that can occur in
the preparation of the system on the
other hand if we take T 2 to 0 we
actually get the NFS equation and and
and then we can also use it in order to
to study a term and this was actually
the method of Marcos said that all from
2011 and and they used it in order to
recover H it should be noticed that here
if we now expand H in in some basis then
actually if the right hand side here in
this equation will have no information
about about H everything in somes
because the state the state of the
system will be only the initial state
which can be arbitrary so there is the
entire information of the of the system
will will be of H actually will be given
on the on the time derivative which is
on the left side and this also implies
this system might not suffer from the
problem of having a gap we can always
pick
an initial state for which this K which
will be as I said independent of H will
have a gap on the other hand if we're
trying to estimate empirically this time
derivative that we might be a bit tricky
we will need to take very short time
measurements and in addition this this
setup is very sensitive of course to
preparation error because we're just
preparing a state and immediately we're
trying to measure it so but as
nevertheless our method is is is
possible it also all ranges of T so it
would be interesting to see exactly in
if there are some ranges in which you
can you know you can benefit from from
both from both ends this is this is an
example of of a time reconstruction and
this is a very very in numeric so what
we actually sorry what we actually did
in this example is the ignore the left
hand side we just try to just try to use
this method just try to use our method
on the homogeneous equation for finite
time and as you can see as time as time
proceeds the the effective role of the
system becomes more and more close to a
steady state system and so the
reconstruction error drops this is the
system was here I think twelve spins
with the random first spin with two body
nearest neighbors and we were trying to
reconstruct the middle eight eight chunk
of the eight spins there okay so let me
let me end in here I will just put some
future some questions and some future
directions we would like to go in so so
far as I was saying all this method has
been either on paper or on computer but
it was not tested on real physical
Hardware so we think it will be
interesting to see how well it performs
in actual natural life in particular you
know in order to do that and in order
for it to be successful it must be able
to somehow handle spam errors which
in-state errors that are due to
systematic errors in stay preparation
and in measurements so as I was saying
when we only look at steady states for
example in a open system with
dissipation then we might not be very
sensitive to preparation error so this
is good but what about measurements we
assume perfect measurement here so for
example I think an interesting direction
would be whether we can take this method
and somehow combine it with gates a
tomography and and using this
combination somehow mitigate the
measurement error and take them into
account when we are measuring our key
metrics so I think that's that's an
interesting direction to to pursue what
about the gaps what can we do at least
theoretically maybe when the gap closes
down so essentially when the gap closes
down that means that we are approaching
a situation in which the homogeneous
equation had used to generate the
extreme case of this is of course the
classical case and as I was I was
telling too late in the classical case
the very equivalent problem in some
sense is the problem of learning a
Boltzmann machine so a Boltzmann machine
can be thought of like the GEEP state of
a classical Hamiltonian for example an
Ising model and and and so in the
classical setup this is just many
particle multivariate probability
distribution and and we are allowed to
do sample from it and the question is of
a given given the abilities to sample
from it can we can we learn the
underlying interaction graph and these W
and theta
weights
and there are many results in this area
there are some tight algorithms which
are you know are optimal in sense that
they match the information theoretic
bound and an important ingredient in all
these algorithm is is the mark of vanity
of this of this probability distribution
it is it is also called random my Markov
Markov random field and you know it
comes from the fact that this if I write
down this some atonium here this sorry
the exponent of this Hamiltonian then it
will factor to a product of two a
product of different terms and this
product it leads to this small community
property so that know if this guy is in
some sense shield it away from the blue
guys then if I condition if I look at
the conditional probability of a on the
green guy and the blue guys it will be
actually independent of the blue guys so
this is my community and it is it is
used in the in the classical learning
algorithm but but strangely I mean not
strange but when you go to the quantum
setup we completely lose my community
and this is because now the terms don't
commute but if they don't commute then
we can use our method so so the question
that I am trying to to ask here is
whether we can somehow maybe use some
sort of classical across or classical
algorithm to handle the situation when
the gap closed down because maybe then
we're in some sense approaching a system
which is in close to being Markovian so
like a toy model to maybe a good point
good point to start but this question is
to try to understand whether we can
learn commuting Hamiltonians in
commuting the matones against our method
will completely fail and can we learn
there Gibb State and we already have
some
preliminary results for example we know
how we can use that we can learn the
gift set of two local commuting
Hamiltonian using the mechanism of Bravo
Andy ollie the idea is to use first our
quantum method just to recognize the the
different projectors in the composition
of problem viale and then feed it to the
classical algorithm a different type
very different a different type of
commuting a maternal that we also can
learn is also is is is committing a
metronome that comes from surface code
of key type so there is also some
interesting structure there okay so this
is it thank you whose copy has just me
thank you
so whoever has questions is now is the
time if you can write your questions and
answers in the box you have a few more
seconds to do that and otherwise well
just say thank you
etai and we'll reconvene with you in 15
minutes for a david's talk
thank you okay thank you you there